fossil news alert we are getting brand
new video from inside a child migrant
influx facility in karizo springs texas
the biden administration finally
allowing in a single camera
after blocking out the media for weeks
white house officials and members of
congress touring the hhs facility
earlier
there are currently 766 miners inside
and as of right now 108 of the children
in this facility
have tested positive for covid and they
are being kept in negative air pressure
dormitories
they say that no child has been released
unless they have two negative tests
and that comes as president biden passed
off one of the toughest challenges of
his presidency yet
to his number two putting vice president
kamla harris in charge
of the border crisis jesse i had a
feeling that there would be some sort of
announcement before tomorrow's press
conference in regards to either a policy
change or a personnel
addition i was thinking someone like a
general jim mattis
perhaps to come in try to coordinate get
it all going but
kamala harris is going to be in charge
kamala harris is no jim mattis this is
great from the president
here kamala you take it it's kind of
like what
president trump did with pence and the
coronavirus
except trump had to be commander in
chief and had to take
charge so he couldn't handle it i don't
think joe biden has that problem he's
happy to sit back
and let kamala take all the heat from
this but that's not going to happen
joe will take heat and he'll pay a big
price but with kamal on the front lines
she's going to get crushed she doesn't
speak the language of the border she
doesn't understand the policy
it's not in her wheelhouse she's going
to have a lot of trouble
explaining why the border is in fact not
open that's the big left-wing talking
point dana oh no
border's not open okay riddle me this
then
if a hundred percent of teenagers are
allowed in
that's not my number that's that's their
policy how's that not open
or if a family unit is allowed in
80 of family units are being allowed in
that's the dhs number from biden
axios reported that that's not my number
so you grab a teen you cross the border
you're in
and not only are you in dana they're
going to buy you a hotel room
they're going to put you on a bus
they're going to put you on an airplane
and send you out
all over the united states of america so
they bring you in
and then they transport you all over the
country
how is that not an open border that just
tells everybody in the western
hemisphere everybody in the world
go to mexico grab a teen pay a cartel
member and walk across
good luck defending that kamala harris
juan what do you think might be
different
when kamala harris takes over
well i think there's first of all let me
just say she's taking on dana the same
role that
vice president biden in the obama
administration
uh played for president obama which is
handling border security so when you
asked me
the question what will change remember
she's a former prosecutor today
in the announcement she said very
clearly she is going to enforce the law
at the border in addition to trying to
impose
some order uh in terms of the process
jesse talks about open borders
those people are going to our agents our
20 000
people who are on the border to make
sure it's not open
and turning themselves over and then
they become part of the asylum process
and that's what's being overwhelmed and
that's why we have a problem
but it's it's an orderly process that
they're trying to find right now they're
trying to open more facilities they're
trying to make sure we have enough
people
that's why fema's down there again this
is all in terms of trying to solve a
problem
and that's why you see in addition she
says she is going to
spend time with people in guatemala in
el salvador
also mexico we've already sent people
down there high-ranking administration
officials
but now harris says she's going to go as
well to try to look at the root
cause of why we're having this influx at
the moment
meanwhile i think you know on the other
side you know i i just
i think i'm i'm becoming like an old
engine here because i say the same thing
every day i don't understand why the
congress
the republicans and the democrats don't
say hey
we're going to fix the asylum system
we're going to make sure that the border
security is something we can all agree
on
let's get something done and let's stop
playing politics
right greg so in this role she will have
to do i would assume
some more public speaking so for example
for example when
mike pence was tasked by president trump
to help coordinate on the covid response
uh he came to the briefing room every
day and he was doing that i don't
i don't know if she will do that but at
some point won't they have to answer the
question
of what did you know during the
transition when career
border patrol officials were telling you
that this very thing was going to happen
yeah and uh i i would advise her
definitely a lot more laughing because i
think that's really going to work at the
border
she um doesn't need to really go on a
fact-finding mission
we know why they came to the border the
mexican president is telling people why
why they're coming to the border because
the bite administration
waved them forward i love how the press
though is supposed to be grateful
for these photos right like they are
getting free samples from costco
and it's like oh yeah we have one camera
as if it's like as if it's like a prom
photo
get all the journalists you get to stand
in line everybody stand in line and then
you get your picture with the migrants
it's just completely it's like i mean
this is so opposite what trump did
and trump got so much grief for just
letting you see this
but this is i mean can we be officially
worried about joe
i mean every day the media demanded that
we question the fitness
the mental fitness or the overall
fitness of trump and yet joe's seen more
lids than a pickle factory
he's not around uh you know and maybe
maybe that's the strategy that the less
you see of joe
the people don't seem to mind his lousy
leadership
because they can't focus their ire on
this guy
unlike trump who did a lot of things but
he was out there all the time so the
press could focus on him
but like joe sucks but you don't see him
so it's okay
well yeah right so during the campaign
katie um he didn't do a lot um i mean
you know
haydn biden but then he won um he hasn't
done a lot here
he'll have his first solo press
conference tomorrow
but his approval rating keeps going up
and they got the legislation passed that
they wanted to pass that
the one thing that's nipping at their
heels big time
is this border issue and that will be i
would imagine front and center in the
press conference tomorrow
yeah definitely but just to respond to
what juan said you know senator lindsey
graham and republicans have introduced
legislation in the past and i think
they're going to do it again to deal
with the asylum issue and democrats
refuse to even negotiate or talk about
it
even though that's the problem here you
know kamala harris was asked about the
border issue whether she would visit
two days ago and she laughed out loud on
the tarmac and said well not today
and i think it's a sign that they're
having a real problem with getting all
of this done but if you don't have
any kind you know diplomacy is great
that's what biden's sending her there to
do to to lead the diplomatic effort to
stop this flow of this
well she's going to have to do diplomacy
not just with officials in places like
honduras
el salvador and other places but also
with mexican cartels who are making 14
million dollars a day through their
human smuggling operation
so if you don't have policies backing up
and hard talk and consequences
for not living up to your diplomatic
mission or agreements
this problem will continue the
administration has created a number of
magnets that
they refuse to turn off and put away so
until they can talk all they want to but
until they change the policies
there's no way this is going to stop and
one more thing following up on greg
they are not showing us any of the
photos from the cbp facilities which are
the ones that are completely overrun and
at maximum capacity they're showing us
photos and video from the secondary uh
facilities where they're already
transferred to so what we used to call
this is
government propaganda and for weeks on
end the white house has said
we're dedicated to showing you what's
going on inside these facilities
we're working at the details they're not
working on any of that they're keeping
people out
and then producing things in the way
that they want people to see them rather
than being transparent
it's a good point about the about the
photos and where they're coming from
thanks everyone coming up the political